at the constitutional convention of 1787
the proposal to replace the existing
articles of confederation with the
federal constitution
were met with fierce opposition
so what's off here is what was met with
fierce opposition
well the proposal the proposal to
replace the existing articles of
confederation with the federal
constitution the proposal is what is
being met with fierce opera opposition
now the proposal this is clearly we're
talking about one proposal the proposal
this is right over here is singular
singular while this right over here
they're saying were met well one you
wouldn't use were if you're talking
about if if it's a singular thing that
that's that's that's that's that it's
happening to that's being met with so
this right over here
this verb is
in the as for
as for if we had many proposals if they
said the proposals to replace the
existing articles of confederation
were met with fierce opposition and then
that would make sense but this this
needs to be this needs to be singular so
let's look at the option so we
definitely don't like it as is let's
rule that out
and so let's see if we if we can see one
that is that where the verb is it
matches the the the singular uh noun
so let's see
at the constitutional convention of 1787
the proposal and you know we could even
for the sake of kind of thinking about
this we can we can ignore to replace the
existing articles of confederation with
the federal constitution so the proposal
having been met with fierce opposition
well once again out now it's not even
giving us it's not even giving us an
action for the proposal it's leaving us
hanging it's a sentence fragment there's
no predicate so we can rule this one
route
the proposal it met with fierce
opposition well now it's kind of giving
us it's giving us a it's giving us a
noun and then a pronoun to refer to the
same thing so that that just
doesn't make any sense the proposal
met with fierce opposition
that looks pretty good and let's just
read it out let's read out the whole
thing
at the constitutional convention of 1787
the proposal to replace the existing
articles of confederation with a federal
constitution
met with fierce opposition
so that seems exactly right a single
proposal can be met with fierce
opposition you wouldn't say were met
with so this seems right now let's just
look at this last one the proposal met
their fierce opposition so who who's
there referring to
they're not talking about you know we
this this this is ambiguous you know
what who is this pro this this kind of
who this possessive pronoun there what
what is
i don't i don't i don't even see who
it's who it's referring to so let's
let's rule that one out so we definitely
like d